from the east coast of the veil the
fingers reach out into the narrow sea
for rocky peninsulas plagued by wind and
rain and barren to all but the hardiest
of weeds the ancestral home of house
Baelish our house began with my
great-grandfather a Braavosi sell sword
who came to the Vale at the invitation
of house Corbray my grandfather raised
himself to the status of hedge Knight
and even managed to acquire a bit of
land and to keep on the smallest of the
fingers though I do believe he often
missed sleeping under his titular hedges
the only thing worse than owning a
dreary and desolate land is owning only
a small portion of it luckily I didn't
spend much time there as a child during
the war of the ninepenny kings a cheap
name for a cheap cause where other men
fought for the king my father fought to
befriend hostile Tully Lord paramount of
the Trident and head of one of the
oldest and greatest houses in Westeros
thanks to my father's heroic efforts
Lord hoster agreed to foster me at
Riverrun with his own children until
then my whole world had been a small
Tower on the girl stained rocks of the
fingers but when I first saw the stone
walls of Riverrun rising from the
Trident towering over me back then I was
a little more easily impressed the boy
and me thought the gods themselves must
live in such a place I soon learned
otherwise Lord Tully son Ned Muir was
quick to ensure I would never forget
myself in their house he nicknamed me
Littlefinger after my size and homeland
and the name was just cruel enough to
stick his sister's lice and Catelyn made
me a pawn in their kissing game traded
back and forth between them for practice
needless to say I enjoyed spending time
with them more than ed Muir and as we
grew older the game began to change as
all games do dice I grew more bold and
cat more demure when Lord Tully
announced cats betrothal to a brood from
the north whom she'd never met I
realized her duty without way any
feelings she had for me
fool that I was I challenged this
Brandon Stark to a duel for her hand he
was a warrior I was a boy if cat had not
intervened he would have killed me and
laughed over my corpse for my insolence
Lord Tully banished me from Riverrun
no matter I had learned everything I
needed by then I would fight my battles
not with swords but with wits a few men
could match me even then house Baelish
might have died out on the rocks of the
fingers I was again a poor Lord with no
allies and no prospects except if I were
lucky the daughter of a middling
merchant then opportunity arose the Mad
King executed that Brandon stark and
incited a rebellion my old friend Lysa
Tully was married off to Jon Arryn lord
of the Vale to cement the alliance
against the Iron Throne bringing her
within my circle again
I quickly capitalized on our former
affection and persuaded her to have me
appointed as controller of customs at
gull town the vales greatest port Wars
burn gold like wildfire when I increased
the port's income tenfold her husband
took notice of this lowly Lord from the
fingers and when the new and profligate
King Robert needed a master of coin who
could find gold where no one else could
why Lord Arryn knew just the man once
house Baelish had no lands no name and
no gold now we have quite a lot of each
what new rung will the next generation
climb let us not be hasty I'm not
finished yet